when I was first asked if I wanted to
make this movie if I wanted to turn this
book into a movie I said no and the
reason why was because that my wife had
given me the book more than 25 years ago
back when we were just dating in college
and we met at Pratt Institute in
Brooklyn and I got interested in
animation and I got accepted into Cal
arts and I was very excited and but I
was terrified and I didn't want to leave
her and I didn't wanna be apart from her
so she gave me her copy of the book and
she quoted the book and said we'll
always be together even when we're apart
you know and she said it is only with
the heart that one can see rightly what
is essential is invisible to the eye and
that that was like you know this
incredible bond between us the book
became a big part of our relationship
and our life and and that was the quote
that stayed with me over the years and
that was the quote that came back to me
when I said no I can't you can't make
this movie you know the book lives in
the imagination of the reader it lives
in the experiences that the reader has
and the book becomes something unique to
everybody and that's why it is
impossible you know the book is and I
really felt like just taking the book
and trying to put it up on the screen
you'd never be able to do that and I I
had my own experience and I knew many
many many people had their own special
specific experience so I said no and
then I I couldn't stop thinking about
that quote though and I couldn't stop
thinking about the significance it had
in my life and and that's when I started
thinking about the possibility of
telling a story about the power of the
book and the experience that one can
have with the book and that's when I
started to look for what could be a very
significant story to tell around the
book that would be born out of the book
and elements from the book and and it
was a way to create a tribute to this
incredibly powerful you know piece of
poetry that that has touched so many
people and I should have brought it I
have I have that copy that and that was
the copy that that stayed with me you
know throughout production and you know
we're we're married we have two children
now and and both of our kids were hugely
inspirational to me and
and actually you just heard the voice of
the little princes our son Riley and
that was temporary at first and he's
made it into the final version the MU
because it no one would let us change it
they everyone loved his voice so much
and so then suddenly you're asked to
direct a very famous French book a very
powerful iconic book in French but that
has had international impact it's a very
international project yeah that's one of
the amazing things about the book is
it's so global it's known in so many
places and it's been translated in a 260
different languages and it was actually
the I was approached by the French
producers who had created a partnership
with the estate and they wanted to make
this movie and they were approaching me
because they wanted to make a movie that
would work globally they didn't want to
just make a French film the the book was
incredibly important and in Japan and
Germany and in so many places and that's
actually why it's incredible to finally
bring the film here and to screen it
here I'm so excited and thrilled to be
able to do that because you know the
film has premiered at the Cannes Film
Festival in May it's been released all
over the world I've been at 10 different
premiere events and 10 different
countries and it's kind of crazy the
journey this film has had and those are
all the dubbed versions so what you saw
tonight was the original version with
the original voices Jeff Bridges
you know originated that character the
animators work to the to the
english-speaking actors and so it's it's
quite an incredible journey the really
interesting thing was you know this is
not a studio project it was not backed
by a studio we we built our financing
from all the territories where the book
is popular and we have a lot of
financing from all over the place but
there's no one studio so it's really
quietest logos at the end were all the
studios is that right yes there's so
many partners because it was such a
non-traditional movie that we needed to
make in order to pay tribute to the book
that we had to not was the that was the
way that they went about it so we have I
moved with my family to Paris for two
years for pre-production and we were
supposed to do all of our production in
Paris and we hired a
of French artists and a lot of artists
from all over the world like we actually
have Peter to seven character designs
for the CG he stayed in Brooklyn and but
we we put together the team and then the
project had to actually move to Montreal
for production and that just turned out
to be the best partner for us to do our
production and the amazing thing that
Montreal allowed us and so a lot of the
French artists moved to Montreal and
then we staffed up with a lot of
Canadian artists but the thing that
Montreal allowed us was the opportunity
to create the CG animation and the
stop-motion animation in the same city
we had to build two different facilities
and we had two entirely different teams
but the the way that it worked out it
was it was quite incredible because
Montreal was a base where we could build
both and actually produce you know both
simultaneously there's this unique
combination of you taking on the world
and at the same time taking your world
with you so how did you balance out
keeping that personal touch and yet at
the same time deal with this
multi-million dollar task well you know
the I think the thing that I learned on
Kung Fu Panda which was even you know an
incredible experience but that film
became a very you know it became a
personal film all the films I've made
you have to stay completely connected
there has to be something that really
keeps you there these these films take
so long and that was the big part of why
I took about nine months before saying
yes to the project cuz I had to I had to
figure out a way to that I could say yes
and go down the road that I knew you
know would end with a film that I wanted
to make and that we could all be proud
of and that we were excited about so it
was really there was a lot of planning
and a lot of pre thinking about it that
once once I had this pitch which was
it's called the magic suitcase and it's
quite an incredible work of art and
hopefully it'll be on display somewhere
if we can see it closer to the release
of the film but yeah it's a it's this
incredible way to sort of communicate
the soul of the project and I had to
pitch
project I've done it hundreds of times
anybody anytime someone new was coming
on the project I would pitch to them and
then it came to the point where I was
pitching to 20 30 people at a time and I
was constantly pitching the project and
every time I was pitching it I was
getting reinvigorated I was getting
reconnected with the book reconnected
with my connection to the book and the
soul of the project and it was like it
was end in it and it was also an
opportunity to shape and improve as as
every time I pitched it I would come
away with ideas and there'd be a spark
you know so that was I think a really an
important part of it even all the way up
to the end so the music was done by Hans
Zimmer and he brought on a friend of his
named Richard Harvey to compose with him
and he said I know what we need to do
but I'm not the guy to do it and this
guy can do it but it was Hans who you
know when I first I had my toe in the
door I mean he's incredibly busy and you
know he did kung fu panda so I basically
I could get the meeting but the firt he
had his arms crossed the first thing he
said is what are you doing to my book
and I was like huh and um you know and I
said have you have you read it he said
well we were all you know every grown-up
was a child once I was I'm really good
and then um he I had the magic suitcase
and I opened it up and it was like it
was crazy because it could really cacked
it to his own childhood and his own
experience growing up and it was quite
extraordinary to go from what are you
doing to you know there's two hours
later you know and he was so that was
another sort of really engaging pitch I
did the same thing with Jeff Bridges and
Rachel McAdams and it's like it was a
great way to engage people and get
people to fall in love with the
potential for what we were making
because you know you've just seen it
it's not like any other movie it was
really intended to be unique and the
book is so unique and the book is so
special and the book is so different it
was really we were trying to find a way
to pay tribute to it in every possible
way and every possible aspect and what
I'm thrilled about is at this point you
know we look at it now and we kind of
step back and every single thing that is
in the movie comes from the book even
the strangest most alien things that
don't seem to be from the book are
actually from a free
or a line or an ocean and that was
something we worked incredibly hard to
craft and because we really wanted to
stay as close to the book as possible
even though we wanted to make it a
cinematic experience and we wanted to
make in a movie and we wanted to go far
from the book at times only to come back
to the book in a powerful and
significant way stop-motion recently has
come to mean almost like clay our puppet
animation as opposed to I believe you're
using paper here or you're using some
kind I mean it yes it looks like a
mixture of stuff so it's a very unique
look so how did he arrive at that well
you know one of the earliest I was asked
I said they said do you want to make a
big CG animated movie you know out of
the book and that was one of the reasons
why I said no and I and I came away I
started making films in stop-motion that
was my first love I always thought I
would work in stop-motion I had an
incredible experience on Kung Fu Panda
and I learned about CG and all the
possibilities there and and I came away
from that going like yeah that I I love
all kinds of animation and and the idea
of being able to use different
techniques to help tell the story is
what really excites me as a filmmaker
and as someone who loves all different
kinds of animation and so that was one
of the ideas that I came back with and I
said I think part of this movie can be
CG but I said the parts that are the
book have to be stop-motion so that we
can stay connected to the book more
poetic we can be you know stylistically
different and you know at that time - it
was it was like wow this is a great way
to be thematic we're talking about the
difference between a child and the
imagination and being a grown-up and
realities I'm like CG is reality and and
stop-motion will be the imagination the
world of the little prince and so it was
one of those ideas that I I never
thought I would be allowed to actually
do you know but I had to push for it and
and and amazingly there was a lot of
support for it it was not easy to to
have two different mediums and a lot of
times people were like oh it's a great
idea but how are you gonna do that like
that's doesn't you know and I was like
big most common question is like how's
it going to work and I'm like I know
it'll work I don't
exactly know how it'll work but I know
it'll work and I know it'll it'll work
for the storytelling it'll work
emotionally in a way that we can't sort
of explain up front so that was really
part of the mission was to maintain this
very big artistic idea and the fact that
we you know when I brought Jamie Cleary
and I was looking at a lot of his work I
mean he's tremendously talented and he
he's done a lot of work with paper and I
was using a lot of his reference a lot
of his work as reference because it just
has this great tactile quality and and
you know it was Jamie and his production
designer Alex Yuhas who were the ones
that came back to me and they said we
could do everything in paper and I'm
like really and they're like well the
armatures inside are gonna be metal and
ball-and-socket but you know it they
were the ones that said we could do the
sand dunes we could do everything could
be made out of paper even the cloth the
clothing the the the faces are made out
of paper clay so they have a paper
texture and it was not easy it was
incredibly difficult and it was really
exciting because we were going to be
able to use again I think stop-motion is
sometimes you know oh that's Halloween
movies or you know there's sort of like
a way that stop-motion is viewed and
this was gonna be a chance for us to do
something really unique and really
different and the contrast between the
stop motion and the CG was going to
really be instrumental in helping to
tell the story and helping to express
those themes about what it means to be a
grown-up in the child and reality and
fantasy and thank you for choosing to be
here with us today thank you thank you
so much thank you thanks